have you guys ever thought about
collaborating on music
i mean like some homeless pimp said we
should yeah like you he was like you
guys get together i didn't know what you
were doing music-wise though i mean just
singing on podcasts uh well i like uh
freestyle down here before yeah i like i
like making rap songs and stuff
like any like any hip-hopper says
it's it's just like yeah it's a very
weird situation because i am good at it
but it's like what am i going to do this
for like you know i put it on the
patreon and stuff but it's uh you know
my worst fear actually is uh because
because nikki came out with that song
about old b sags yeah
nikki glazier oh and
um
i know i don't know why i said it like
that yeah but then uh you know on skanks
they were like making fun of it and on
bonfire they called feeny yesterday
right and and uh because feeney liked
her post so they were running him they
were doxing him going feeny why did you
like nikki's boat blah blah blah and he
threw me under the bus he's like well
you know some people
you know uh do music when they think
their career is i was like you think
that's me i just like making music jim
and i have actually we've
specifically
we like we've said i don't want to talk
about that song and that's it like we
and we've gotten [ __ ]
for not [ __ ] on it like we haven't
even supported it but the fact that we
haven't [ __ ] on it has been like you
guys are [ __ ] phony yeah if you stand
for nothing you die for everything
that's like i mean it's not wrong and me
and canon when we were coming back from
boston we're listening to the legion of
skanks episode and we're cracking up and
then there was just a silence and i'm
like this is my worst fear is that they
find out that i'm making rap music and
then they just [ __ ] trash me so then
yesterday what else would they do if
they heard it mm-hmm do you think like
don't [ __ ] talk about it dawg
don't [ __ ] talk about it oh geez
i mean no i'm confident in it where it's
like
a part of it and this is gonna sound
like i'm trying to uh save my own ass in
some way
but a part of it for me i also kind of
get joy about how
funny it is that i'm doing it when i'm
not trying to be funny i i'm also like
this is [ __ ] hilarious how serious
this is oh yeah that's a fun way to go
like from an outsider like you can see
outside yourself and going it's just a
funny scenario but also you do think
it's good i do think it's good yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah i believe that do you
want to hear one
no please pretty much so
i do want to hear one it's a matter of
problems
why wait
i won't play it no
well no i have it on this thing right
here you don't have the instrumental by
itself i don't want to do it live why
because i i don't know i just don't want
it i mean it sounds probably sounds
better live you think so i think so
here's the thing is that because it's
going to be it's two songs it's like it
cuts into another song i don't want to
do this anymore no i just think that a
phone to a mic is not going to be very
good quality people are more likely to
make fun of it that way you want to do
it live so it's like this is the thing i
can i can like spit a verse if you want
but i have to
i have to
read i have to read my thing just like
the baby yeah drake did too remember you
gotta gotten a lot of [ __ ] for this
gotten a lot of [ __ ] for you yeah
um
with one of the people from the red the
rap stations walks over here's brendan
and goes you're coming with me pal yeah
sway fix yourself
like what's that
the future
where the [ __ ] is this one okay i mean
uh uh uh greg you've got you're you're
not a rapper no no but you do more of a
an electronic music well here's like the
i don't even know i could see this is my
big fear is that we started doing this
stuff i was like ah like i don't want
people to think i'm scared like it's not
that it's not serious what happened was
my friend does beats he makes music
he come pandemic he came over he opened
a computer he handed me a microphone he
said
sing into this
i sang for about two hours he never
laughed never smiled shut the computer
three days later he cut it all up and
sent it back he went this is the summer
gym at 20 20.
all right man like it's just it's just
like a free thought kind of like yeah i
do think it's funny it's yeah i enjoy it
yeah it's not like i'm not rhyming and i
don't have a good voice right it's just
sometimes you're just saying phrases you
just phrase it it's just anything that's
crazy it's just a you know it's just a
free word association [ __ ] also can i
plug a show yeah this saturday we're
being at grove 34. night cream is that's
the name of the band night cream night
cream we're going to be doing a live
show at uh grove 34 um
in astoria so come by there's like six
there's i think there's only six chairs
in this place so
that's like hey if three of you want to
come by my brother will be there so i
have to save a seat for him uh
i saw you guys do uh like your your set
at new york comedy club and it was
[ __ ] hilarious oh it was really funny
he like goes out in the crowd and
everything and yeah it's all like crowd
work yeah it was like i saw the matrix
song oh i like that oh yeah that's okay
oh he hates the single
classic classic musicians that's the
deep cuts we like yeah no i'm not really
a real slim shady guy
it's not my favorite like radiohead like
we don't do creep
we don't do it yeah
also i we did this song called mr go
down which is just stupid and uh so
catchy though yeah it is but my friend
who is it on youtube it's on youtube can
you look up mr go down by night cream my
favorite oh god i'm gonna walk out
my friend uh
who shoots videos for me uh i was like
hey man do you think he could do a music
video and he goes did you not realize
that i came from the rap video
world and he shot this video and it
looks
so good it looks a real video yeah he
like made a real good video for mr go
down which we never sang more than once
because i could not memorize the lyrics
and or it was a one-shot take okay let's
listen to a little bit if you don't mind
all right yeah it's a funny right don't
be good we are going to get a live
performance it is so good
can i can i send up the beat that this
song yeah please do uh travis give
brendan an email that's good for him to
send that to as we listen to uh mr go
down yeah so she'll also be noted the
other guy in this band dan haroomy he's
the guy who does all the music plays
bass through the whole song and the
video there's no bass it's just this
scene and i didn't even realize it he
just showed up with a big bass guitar
plays it through the whole song there's
no bass there's no bass guitar in the
song
that's awesome
i love it to the 90s mtv font music
video font yeah it took me an hour to
look that up
[Music]
it's so catchy
[Music]
and there's racist voices that just show
up that's good
not you
everyone else your hair looks good too
did you get a haircut for this always
by the way could you hit pause for a
second
your hair looks nice was a nice thing to
say
and then following it up with did you
get a haircut for this is almost like
well it feels condescending yeah like
why would you have to why would you add
that it's an innocent question it is i
answer the question
that's awesome so funny last time i was
on it was really a lot of nice comments
and i just know that as soon as i walk
out of here so many people are going to
be [ __ ] on mr go down the way i'm
going to blow my goddamn brains out you
know what but for everybody that shits
on it you'll find somebody that's like
this sucks
yeah
[Music]
sex with me that's a fun party i guess
that's a good word
i don't know i just spoke into a
microphone he recorded and edited it
dude this whole video he kept having to
play it and i'd have to like wait what
did i say again all right just trying to
lip sing
it took a while a long time but he shot
it really good it looks great yeah this
guy alex adams he's the best oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah i know him yeah let's do
a little more yeah
[Laughter]
who runs a convenience store who wants
to be a sex dj and then two men come in
and everyone starts [ __ ] and he's
playing the song i don't know that he
comes across but that was the story so
he's not
in the sex orgy no the dj he's the dj
sexy the sex dj running a sex dj out of
a bodega and that's and then mr go down
comes in who just goes down on everybody
he's mr go down yeah
that's awesome he goes down to everybody
that's what he's known for i love it
i love that it has a meaning yeah it's
also like it's good to learn i think i
didn't know that a sex dj was a thing
there were djs for sex yeah sex dj's
trying to get into sex world man
[Laughter]
dan is also really funny he's hilarious
yeah
every time his stand-up comes up on my
tick tock i like i go through like a
whole of of his [ __ ] i also love that it
does appear that he's playing chords on
the bass to line up with the keyboard
[Laughter]
yeah he's great that was great that was
great
well
yeah that was really good
so
uh yeah mr go down the cream supreme
night cream the album is the cream
supreme it's available on spotify
uh
we have three downloads prom you know
the dif it's just like yours is so funny
and you're also naturally [ __ ]
hilarious and i'm just like sincerely
being like yo we gotta have you come to
a track i could do that we got it well i
gotta do that if it's not you know he's
gotta audition first i do have to
audition well this is the audition all
right
let's do
it okay
sag daddy in the house
sag daddy to god
all right hold on
i thought he had already started yo i'm
ill smoking craving pills and a weed
smoker who self-loathing toting ho hoes
and cheap clothing i got one hoe bro and
i'm addicted to ramona and when i'm
drowning in her [ __ ] she just leaves me
in there floating got a notion i'll be
posting on a boat and getting throated
by a hoad who's called a throw cop but
could barely fit the whole thing can we
motion for a recess boson's got me
depressed i'm so sick of ocean sickness
people minding all my beeswax i can't
relax for a second y'all at second place
i'm engaged in every page they call me
nicholas cage i don't engage with all my
fans cause some are crazy and demanding
hand me weed inside my hand and then get
out my face i swear to god i got a guy
that got a tattoo or designer he like
pandas ain't got stab that left it where
they filmed the wire i got high and
bought an air fryer and a hair dryer
amazon is evil but i'm still on there
buying i'm gonna start tugging at hearts
giving them art trash in the room you
got the broom blessing of who knew i do
to these grooms honeymoons at the zoo i
lost it
wait go
do you think you are doing silver spoon
goons put good knives in our steaks with
a night uh [ __ ]
you got this go brandon
he's choking
it's like that eight mile thing he's
choking no that's pretty and that was
pretty much it
[Laughter]
i'm so mad that you you gave up because
i was waiting this whole time just to go
what happened yeesh
but i won't do it that was great man
yeah
thank you
yeah take the compliment every good rap
ends with yeah that's pretty much it
look very interesting greg stone uh of
course the host of friday night greg
available every wednesday morning on all
streaming platforms as well as greg
stonecomedy on youtube and patreon.com
the greg stone zone you can follow him
at greg stone on twitter and where is
the uh where's the show in oh uh grove
34 in astoria it's this saturday um just
follow me on instagram and i'm going to
post about it i don't know what time
it's at uh greg stone underscore
whatever but yeah if we can get about
six people there it'll be a good time
okay well we'll see yeah
we'll see
and uh
brendan sagelow you can follow him at
brendan sagalow
s-a-g-a-l-o-w his album not now more
than ever is available on all streaming
services and of course here's the
scenario with mike cannon and mike
feeney is available weekly on all
platforms as well as on patreon
brendansagalowcomedy.com
yes and uh thanks for hanging guys this
was fun and i hope this was fun i hope
brandon that this helped
um it probably hurt but i feel like it
helped i hope it had an effect it
definitely had an effect things are
going to go downhill
as long as they're moving